Late last year, I got some not-so-great health news that kind of scared the hell out of me. Basically, I was diagnosed with mild emphysema, lung disease, and two-- what they're calling small, benign nodules. One on each lung. It's like scar tissue. I'm trying to focus on the words mild, small, and benign.
去年年末，我收到了一些不太好的健康消息，这让我感到非常害怕。简单来说，我被诊断出患有轻度肺气肿，这是一种肺部疾病，还有两个他们所说的良性小结节。每个肺上各有一个。就像疤痕组织一样。我正试着把注意力集中在“轻度”、“小”和“良性”这几个词上。
The cause wasn't mysterious. I'd been a daily cigarette smoker for about 35 years. It used to be a pack a day when I was younger, sometimes more. I'd cut it down to maybe a half or a third of that later on. And I'd been meaning to quit for a long time. But I just never tried to, not really. And now it felt like I had no choice, which, before I tell you what happened next, I feel like I should explain what a huge change that was going to be.
病因并不神秘。我当了大约35年的每日吸烟者。年轻时我曾经一天抽一包，有时甚至更多。后来我把量减少到了那时的二分之一或三分之一。我很久以来一直打算戒烟。但我从来没有真正尝试过。现在感觉我别无选择，在告诉你们后来发生什么之前，我觉得我应该解释一下这将是一个多么巨大的改变。
I always say I started smoking when I was 15 and started inhaling when I was 16.
我常说我15岁开始抽烟，16岁开始吸入。
Partly, I just wanted to be like the people in the British TV dramas I was watching on PBS, pulling these perfect, little, white cylinders out of silver cases that snapped shut. I remember I painted an empty metal Band-Aid container light blue and kept my Salem menthols in there, puffing at them in my parents' driveway.
部分原因是，我只是想变得像我在PBS公共电视台上看的英剧里的人物一样，从咔哒一声关上的银色烟盒里掏出这些完美的白色小圆柱体。我记得我曾把一个空的金属创可贴盒涂成浅蓝色，把我的塞勒姆薄荷烟放在里面，在我父母的车道上抽着它们。
In my 30s and 40s, I was the guy in the friend group that always had cigarettes. I'd smoke during the shortest of walks, like from this office to the hotel bar across the street. I'd smoke after a 10-mile training run for a half marathon. You smoke in your car, someone would ask. And I'd say, yeah, that's why I bought it. Whenever I imagined myself stranded in the woods or on a life raft in the middle of the ocean, the panic I felt was about not having enough cigarettes with me.
在我的三四十岁时，我成了朋友圈里总是带烟的那个人。我会在最短的步行路程中抽烟，比如从这间办公室走到街对面的酒店酒吧。我会在跑完10英里半程马拉松训练后抽烟。有人会问，你在车里也抽吗？我会说，是的，这就是我买车的原因。每当我幻想自己被困在森林里或大洋中央的救生筏上时，我感到恐慌的原因都是因为没有带足够的烟。
So the prospect of stopping for good always felt like trying to strand myself on purpose, like everything in me opposed it. The emphysema diagnosis was in early November. I figured I'd put off quitting until after Christmas when I didn't have to work for a bit. Whenever I went too long without smoking, my cognition would slow down to where I could barely think.
所以，彻底戒烟的前景总是让我感觉像是在故意让自己陷入绝境，好像我身体里的每一部分都在抵触它。肺气肿诊断是在11月初。我心想，我等到圣诞节后再戒烟，那时候我可以休息一段时间，不用工作。每当我太久不抽烟，我的认知能力就会变慢，慢到我几乎无法思考。
December 28, I'll stop, I told myself, and started practically counting down the cigarettes. I recorded voice memos through all of this. This one's from December 21, a week before quitting day.
“12月28日，我就戒烟，”我对自己说，然后几乎开始倒数香烟的数量。在此期间，我录制了语音备忘录。这一段录于12月21日，距离戒烟日还有一周。
This is one of the last times I'll be sitting here, smoking out the window, looking at the World Trade Tower.
这是我最后几次坐在这里，对着窗外抽烟，看着世界贸易大厦。
[EXHALES]
[呼气声]
And then I guess going forward, I'll just sit here and-- I don't know-- think or something.
我想接下来，我大概只会坐在这里，然后——我不知道——思考或者什么的。
This is how much of a smoker I was. I didn't even realize that when you don't smoke, you don't have to go and sit by the window. But the thing I'm really here to tell you about is how I was planning to quit. I was going to read a book, "the book" for people in my situation. It's called Allen Carr's Easy Way to Stop Smoking.
我是个这么“资深”的烟民。我甚至没意识到，当你不抽烟时，你根本不必跑去坐在窗边。但我真正想告诉你们的是我打算如何戒烟。我打算读一本书，那是给处境和我一样的人准备的“那本书”。书名是《亚伦·卡尔的简单戒烟法》。
You might have heard of it. It's sold millions and millions of copies. It's pretty famous. A lot of famous people read it and then kvell about it on television. James Spader is a fan.
你可能听说过它。它卖出了成千上万本。它非常出名。很多名人读过它，然后在电视上对此大加赞赏。詹姆斯·斯派德就是个粉丝。
It was so easy. It was so perfect. And it was all because of this book.
它太简单了。太完美了。而这一切都是因为这本书。
Ellen DeGeneres--
艾伦·德杰尼勒斯——
The Easy Way to Stop Smoking, Allen Carr wrote it. And everybody who reads the book stops. And so I stopped. And I'm so glad I quit because I had a monkey on--
《简单戒烟法》，亚伦·卡尔写的。每个读过这本书的人都戒掉了。所以我戒了。我很高兴我戒了，因为我曾……
Ashton Kutcher--
阿什顿·库彻——
And the great thing is, while you're reading the book, you get to smoke. He tells you when to light up. He's like, all right, light one now. And you're like, oh, absolutely.
最棒的是，你在读这本书的时候，还可以抽烟。他会告诉你什么时候点烟。他就像是说，好的，现在点上一根。而你会觉得，哦，当然。
That part's a big selling point.
那部分是一个很大的卖点。
He insists that you keep smoking while you're reading the book. And then when you finish it, you stop.
他坚持让你在读这本书的同时继续抽烟。等你读完了，你就戒掉了。
My method is known as the Easyway.
我的方法被称为“简单戒烟法（Easyway）”。
This is Allen Carr, recorded back in 2005.
这是亚伦·卡尔，录制于2005年。
And it will enable any smoker to quit immediately, permanently, and actually enjoy the process. Before you dismiss my claims, bear in mind that I've been proving them for over 20 years. That's why my book and global network of clinics are so successful.
它将使任何烟民能够立即、永久地戒烟，并真正享受这个过程。在你驳回我的主张之前，请记住，我已经证明了这一点超过20年。这就是为什么我的书和全球诊所网络如此成功。
This book is the only thing that's ever given me a shred of hopefulness about stopping smoking. It literally always felt impossible in the past. And now here's this guy saying that not only would I be able to do it, but actually be happy about it. That's the true measure of success, Allen Carr says, not just stopping, but becoming a happy non-smoker.
这本书是我戒烟过程中唯一让我产生一丝希望的东西。过去它确实总是感觉是不可能的。而现在这个家伙说，我不但能做到，甚至还会为此感到快乐。亚伦·卡尔说，这才是衡量成功的真正标准，不仅仅是停止吸烟，而是成为一个快乐的非吸烟者。
I couldn't imagine being happy not smoking. I couldn't imagine that a bunch of words could get someone to stop feeling an incredibly strong urge, that words alone could make something that seems so impossible actually happen. What type of witchery was afoot here in this book?
我无法想象不抽烟会感到快乐。我无法想象一堆文字就能让人停止感受极其强烈的欲望，无法想象仅仅靠文字就能让一件看起来如此不可能的事情真正发生。这本书里到底施了什么魔法？
And all the stories in today's show are about that, people casting spells to try to make people completely change their directions in life in some way. Oh, and you get to listen to me try to quit smoking. Stay with us.
今天节目里的所有故事都是关于这个的，人们施展咒语试图让别人在某种程度上彻底改变生活方向。哦，你还会听到我试图戒烟的经历。敬请收听。
Act One, The Straw that Broke Joe Camel's Back. We're actually not sure about that title. There's a couple of others here that we liked.
第一幕，压垮乔·骆驼的最后一根稻草。我们实际上对这个标题不太确定。这里还有几个我们喜欢的标题。
Act One, Can I Still be a Joker and a Midnight Toker?
第一幕，我还能做一个小丑和一个深夜瘾君子吗？
Or this one, Act One, the Unbearable Lighterlessness of Being.
或者这个，第一幕，生命中不可承受的无火之轻。
Anyway, the book is relatively short and really, really repetitive. He says you have to follow every instruction to the letter. And the way it works-- Carr says most people who try to convince you not to smoke will tell you the reasons you shouldn't, health risks, all the money you spend, whatever. But he says smokers already know all of that. If any of that actually worked, Allen Carr says, you'd have quit by now.
总之，这本书相对简短，而且真的非常重复。他说你必须严格按照每一个指示去做。它是这样运作的——卡尔说，大多数试图说服你不抽烟的人会告诉你你不该抽烟的原因：健康风险、你花的钱，等等。但他说烟民已经知道所有这些了。如果这些东西真的有用的话，亚伦·卡尔说，你早就戒了。
Now what he does instead is the opposite. He names all of the reasons you give for smoking, all the things you like about it or think it's offering you. And he carefully explains why every one of those reasons is bogus. He describes it as a kind of deprogramming, ultimately removing any desire for a cigarette.
他所做的是反其道而行之。他列举了你抽烟的所有理由，你喜欢它或认为它提供给你的所有东西。然后他仔细解释了为什么这些理由每一个都是虚假的。他将其描述为一种“反编程”，最终消除对香烟的任何欲望。
And a lot of the precepts make a lot of sense. For instance, he says smokers believe that smoking helps them focus and concentrate. But he says they're just kidding themselves. That's just an illusion. All smoking does is remove the distraction of nicotine withdrawal. So you only think it's helping you think better.
很多戒条确实很有道理。例如，他说烟民认为吸烟有助于他们集中注意力和思考。但他说是他们自己在骗自己。那只是幻觉。吸烟唯一的作用就是消除了尼古丁戒断带来的干扰。所以你只是以为它在帮你更好地思考。
There are tons of fallacies like that, he says. And smokers perpetuate them without even realizing it. This is from the book. He says, "smokers claim that the cigarette relaxes them and helps them to handle stressful situations. But they also claim that it helps them get going in the morning and that it gives them a boost. How can a drug that relaxes you or relieves stress also stimulate you? This contradiction illustrates the truth about smoking. The cigarette just doesn't do any of the things we tell ourselves it does."
他说有无数这样的谬论。而烟民们甚至在不知不觉中延续了它们。这是书里写的。他说：“烟民声称香烟能让他们放松，帮助他们处理压力情况。但他们也声称香烟能帮助他们在早上提神，给他们带来动力。一种让你放松或缓解压力的药物怎么可能同时刺激你呢？这种矛盾揭示了吸烟的真相。香烟根本做不到我们告诉自己它能做到的任何事情。”
I should say he distinguishes Easyway from just going cold turkey, or what he calls the willpower method. Those poor souls aren't real nonsmokers, he says. They're just smokers who aren't letting themselves smoke. And what kind of life is that? Whereas if you have no desire to smoke anymore, you don't need willpower. You also won't be irritable or depressed or gain weight or any of the things that, according to most people, make quitting hard.
我应该说，他把“简单戒烟法”与单纯的“硬戒法”（或他所说的意志力法）区别开来。他说，那些可怜的灵魂不是真正的非吸烟者。他们只是不让自己抽烟的烟民。那样的生活有什么意思呢？而如果你不再有抽烟的欲望，你就不需要意志力。你也不会变得易怒、抑郁或体重增加，而大多数人认为这些是戒烟困难的原因。
Also, the reported success rate for willpower alone is really low. And it depends on who you ask. But it might be as low as 3% to 5%.
此外，据报道，单靠意志力戒烟的成功率非常低。这取决于你问谁。但可能低至3%到5%。
Cutting down doesn't work, Allen Carr says, because it just makes every cigarette seem that much more precious. That's why he says to just smoke as you normally would while you read the book.
亚伦·卡尔说，减量法是行不通的，因为它只会让每一根烟看起来都更加珍贵。这就是为什么他说你在读这本书的时候要按照平时的习惯抽烟。
Also, he really wants you to sit with it. How's the taste? What's it really feel like, going down into your lungs? And don't even get him started on nicotine replacement therapy. Patches, gum, all that stuff, that's just going to keep you wanting cigarettes. He'd get into arguments on this point, like this one on Sky TV, with someone from a smoking cessation charity.
此外，他确实希望你仔细感受它。味道怎么样？当它进入你的肺部时，感觉到底如何？更别提尼古丁替代疗法了。贴片、口香糖，所有那些东西，只会让你继续渴望香烟。他会在这一点上与人争论，就像在天空电视台（Sky TV）上，与一个戒烟慈善机构的人辩论时那样。
It's not nicotine replacement therapy. It's nicotine maintenance. You're actually giving them nicotine, the drug they're addicted to. And that keeps their body craving nicotine. It's absolute nonsense.
那不是尼古丁替代疗法。那是尼古丁维持疗法。你实际上是在给他们尼古丁，即他们上瘾的药物。这让他们的身体继续渴望尼古丁。这完全是胡说八道。
You are giving them nicotine. But it's stepping them down gradually so that they can come off it.
你是在给他们尼古丁。但这是在循序渐进地帮他们减少用量，让他们能够戒除。
Can you tell me the proved rates of success on nicotine replace?
你能告诉我尼古丁替代疗法的确切成功率吗？
It's much greater than willpower alone.
它远高于单靠意志力。
That's what the adverts say. It's four times greater. Four times greater than what?
那是广告里说的。它高出四倍。比什么高出四倍？
Four times greater than just using willpower alone.
比单靠意志力高出四倍。
But willpower doesn't work.
但意志力根本没用。
No, it doesn't--
不，并没有——
So it's four times greater than nothing.
所以这只是比“什么都不做”高出四倍。
Well, and if you--
好吧，如果你——
Allen Carr never had any training in psychology or medicine. He says one day, he just realized what a con smoking is, and took things from there, started working with individual clients in the early '80s, then group seminars, then the book, and ultimately, an organization that operates in more than 50 countries around the world.
亚伦·卡尔从未受过心理学或医学训练。他说有一天，他只是意识到吸烟是一场骗局，然后就从那里开始，在80年代初开始与个人客户合作，然后是小组研讨会，然后是这本书，最终，建立了一个在世界50多个国家运营的组织。
For my money, his cred was even better than that of a therapist or a psychiatrist. He was a smoker for about as long as I was, and much heavier, sometimes a hundred cigarettes a day. He had tried to quit a lot of times before hitting upon his method, at which point he just stopped on a dime. If only he'd figured it out way sooner. Allen Carr died of lung cancer in 2006. He hadn't been a smoker for about 20 years.
依我看，他的可信度甚至比治疗师或精神科医生还要高。他当烟民的时间和我差不多长，而且烟瘾大得多，有时一天抽一百根。他在找到这个方法之前尝试过很多次戒烟，就在那个时刻他一下子就彻底停下来了。要是他早点想通就好了。亚伦·卡尔于2006年死于肺癌。他已经有大约20年没抽烟了。
I felt this growing excitement as I read the book. I was starting to beat out my fear of quitting. At one point I wrote in a notebook, "Allen Carr is right about the taste. It's foul. Smoke felt bad going down my lungs. I think my thinking about smoking has genuinely changed."
读这本书时，我感到越来越兴奋。我开始克服我对戒烟的恐惧。有一次我在笔记本上写道：“亚伦·卡尔关于口感的说法是对的。这味道很恶心。烟进入我的肺部感觉很不舒服。我想我关于吸烟的想法真的改变了。”
The night before my final day of smoking, I felt like a kid on Christmas Eve Eve, sort of thrilled and wishing the day would just hurry up and get here already. Allen Carr said this might happen. The next night, December 27, I smoked my final cigarette, a sort of a ritual built into the process. For some reason, I wanted to be outside, walking the neighborhood. I smoked it maybe faster than any cigarette ever, knocked the burning ember off the butt, threw it in somebody's trashcan, and said, out loud, goodbye cigarettes.
我戒烟前夜，感觉就像平安夜的孩子，既兴奋又希望这一天快点到来。亚伦·卡尔说这可能会发生。第二天晚上，12月27日，我抽了最后一根烟，这是整个过程内置的一种仪式。出于某种原因，我想要去外面，在社区里走走。我抽的速度可能是有史以来最快的，把烟蒂上燃烧的余烬敲掉，扔进别人的垃圾桶，然后大声说：再见，香烟。
And when I woke up the next day, I wanted a cigarette more than I ever remember wanting one first thing in the morning, which is not what the book says is supposed to happen. I don't know what I did or didn't do or what exactly went wrong. But suddenly, the way felt anything but easy.
第二天早上醒来时，我想抽烟的欲望比我记忆中任何时候早上醒来想抽烟的欲望都要强烈，这与书里说的完全不一样。我不知道是我做对了什么或做错了什么，或者到底哪里出了问题。但突然间，戒烟过程变得一点也不轻松。
In the book, over and over again, Allen Carr says some version of, the actual physical withdrawal from nicotine is a very mild, slightly empty, insecure feeling. It's so mild that most smokers don't even notice it throughout their smoking lives.
在书中，亚伦·卡尔反复提到类似的说法：尼古丁的实际身体戒断反应是一种非常轻微、空虚、不安的感觉。它太轻微了，以至于大多数烟民在他们吸烟的一生中甚至都没注意到它。
I've also heard that the physical withdrawal only lasts three days. Or is it a week? Or is it three weeks? And after that, it's merely psychological. I've heard the individual cravings last anywhere from three to five minutes and then they pass.
我还听说身体戒断反应只持续三天。或者是一周？还是三周？在那之后，它纯粹是心理上的。我听说个人的烟瘾发作持续三到五分钟，然后就会过去。
All I can say is in my experience, all of this is utter horseshit. I don't even understand the concept of individual cravings. In my case, withdrawal has meant a constant, crazed yearning that varies in tolerability throughout the day.
我只能说以我的经验，所有这些简直是胡扯。我甚至不理解所谓“个人烟瘾”的概念。对我而言，戒断意味着一种持续的、疯狂的渴望，在一天中随着忍耐度的不同而起伏。
This is how I described it a couple of weeks in. "It's like a worldwide itch, like all of my limbs are phantom limbs, like I swallowed a live animal much larger than me that promptly died.
这是我戒烟两周后对它的描述：“这就像是一种全球性的瘙痒，就像我所有的肢体都是幻肢，就像我吞下了一只比我大得多的活体动物，它立即死在了里面。
And now I have to walk around with it inside of me, soul and all. Or it's like opening all these awful, little packages in which there's something I can't see, that painfully stings me. And there's no telling how many more I have to open, nor for how long. It is the thing I'm thinking about more than any other thing and more than all of the other things." This was on January 13.
现在我不得不带着它四处走动，连带着灵魂一起。或者这就像打开所有这些糟糕的小包裹，里面有我看不见的东西，刺痛着我。而且不知道还要打开多少个，也不知道还要持续多久。这就是我脑子里想得最多的东西，比其他所有事情加起来都要多。”这是1月13日。
I've had a bunch of snacks. And nothing makes it better. Literally nothing makes it better. Everything makes-- everything that I do instead of smoking makes me want to smoke more. This is the worst day of the nonsmoking that there's been so far. Day-- what is it? We're now going into day 17.
我吃了一堆零食。但什么都不能缓解它。真的什么都不能让它好转。我做的每一件事——我做每一件代替抽烟的事，都让我更想抽烟。这是我戒烟以来最糟糕的一天。第……现在是第17天了吗？
I don't fucking know. I don't know. They're hard. They're all hard.
我他妈不知道。我不知道。很难熬。每一天都很难熬。
The thing about thinking something's going to be easy is that when it's ultimately not, it makes it that much harder, like yeah, if I can't do it, I must be an idiot. And thinking back on some of the passages in the book, I felt gaslit, like my lived experience was being questioned. This is Allen Carr on a British talk show sometime in the early aughts.
以为事情会很容易的后果就是，当它最终并没有那么容易时，会让它变得更加困难，就像是，如果我做不到，我一定是白痴。回顾书中的一些段落，我感觉自己被操控了，就像我的真实生活体验遭到了质疑。这是亚伦·卡尔在21世纪初某个英国脱口秀节目上的表现。
We talk about these terrible withdrawal pangs. You say to somebody, well, where did it hurt you? Where? Show me.
我们谈论这些可怕的戒断痛苦。你问某人，好吧，它哪里让你疼了？哪里？指给我看。
I can say exactly where. January 18, it's like three weeks in. I had this attack. I was on the corner in my neighborhood, trying to decide whether to go home or go to the bar. I chose the bar. And my brain was like, oh, we're walking a bunch. Time for a cigarette, huh?
我可以明确指出哪里。1月18日，大约三周后。我发作了。当时我站在社区的一个角落里，试图决定是回家还是去酒吧。我选择了酒吧。我的大脑就在说，哦，我们走了一大段路了。该抽根烟了吧？
And I said, no, we don't do that anymore. And my brain was like, what do you mean? It's time for a cigarette. And I said, no, it's not. And then it's like I was physically punched in the solar plexus with something electric that sent a shock up through my face and head. I screamed.
我说，不，我们不再那样做了。我的大脑说，什么意思？是时候抽烟了。我说，不，不是。然后就像我的太阳神经丛被人用电击拳头狠狠击中，那股冲击力直冲我的脸部和头部。我尖叫起来。
crazy. I just literally turned to walk in the other direction. I just went, fuck, Like fuck. Oh, my fucking god. Well, it better get better at some point.
太疯狂了。我真的转身走向了反方向。我只是喊道：“该死。”就像，该死。哦，天呐。好吧，这迟早会好起来的吧。
It got worse. I've gained weight. I've been drinking more. I went a month with no nicotine at all and then gave in and started having a nicotine lozenge here and there. I have about two a day now, which naturally made me relitigate everything Allen Carr had said. It also made me wonder why wasn't this working for me if it works for so many people.
结果变得更糟了。我体重增加了。我喝得更多了。我有一个月完全没碰尼古丁，然后屈服了，开始在这里或那里含一颗尼古丁含片。我现在每天大约吃两颗，这自然让我重新审视亚伦·卡尔所说的一切。这也让我怀疑，如果它对那么多人有效，为什么对我无效呢？
So I started looking for answers. And I stumbled across this podcast that was way more revelatory to me about my addiction than anything in the book.
所以我开始寻找答案。我偶然发现了这个播客，它比书里的任何东西都更能启发我对成瘾的认识。
Welcome to The Huberman Lab Podcast, where we discuss science and science-based tools for everyday life.
欢迎来到胡伯曼实验室播客，在这里我们讨论日常生活中的科学和科学工具。
You might be familiar with Andrew Huberman. He's kind of a neuroscience rock star now, has a lab at Stanford School of Medicine where he researches neurobiology and ophthalmology. But apart from that, he's made it a personal mission to explain how your brain and body work so you can maybe make better choices. And he has an episode on nicotine, which made me feel like someone had put their hand on my shoulder, looked me in the eye, and said you, Sir, are not insane.
你可能熟悉安德鲁·胡伯曼。他现在算是个神经科学摇滚明星，在斯坦福医学院有一个实验室，专门研究神经生物学和眼科学。除此之外，他有一个个人使命，就是解释你的大脑和身体是如何运作的，这样你也许能做出更好的选择。他有一期关于尼古丁的节目，让我感觉有人把手放在我的肩膀上，看着我的眼睛对我说：先生，你没有疯。
Again, Allen Carr's central premise is that all the things smokers like about smoking, that it relaxes us and focuses us and gives us a boost, Carr says that the only thing we're feeling is just the withdrawal going away. But according to Huberman, that's not true at all. Scientists have been studying the brain chemistry of this for years, decades.
再次重申，亚伦·卡尔的核心前提是，烟民喜欢吸烟的一切——放松、专注、动力——卡尔说我们感觉到的唯一东西只是戒断反应在消失。但据胡伯曼所说，那完全不是真的。科学家们多年、几十年来一直在研究其大脑化学机制。
And just to be super abbreviated about it here-- podcast is two hours long-- nicotine juices up your brain with these three chemicals: dopamine-- you've heard of dopamine, people think it causes pleasure. But it's also the thing that makes you want pleasure. It motivates you, makes you strive, pursue.
为了在这里极度精简地概括——播客长达两个小时——尼古丁会用这三种化学物质激发你的大脑：多巴胺——你听说过多巴胺，人们认为它产生愉悦感。但它也是让你想要愉悦感的东西。它激励你，让你奋斗，去追求。
Acetylcholine, which I had never heard of, helps you focus, come up with ideas, plus-- this is weird-- you have acetylcholine receptors on your muscles too, which Huberman says could explain why some people feel more physically relaxed on nicotine-- and then epinephrine, which you could just call adrenaline. So when Allen Carr says the nicotine itself doesn't give you a boost-- it gives you a boost. And when you put all of that together--
乙酰胆碱，我以前从未听说过，能帮助你专注，想出点子。此外——这很奇怪——你的肌肉上也有乙酰胆碱受体，胡伯曼说这可以解释为什么有些人觉得尼古丁让他们身体上更放松——还有肾上腺素。所以当亚伦·卡尔说尼古丁本身不会给你带来动力时——它确实给你带来了动力。当你把这一切加在一起时——
We now have a very clear picture. Reward pathways are turned on. Attention is turned on. Alertness is turned on. You feel better than you felt a few minutes ago. Your blood pressure is up. Your heart rate is up. Your preparedness for thinking is elevated as well. And yet your body is somewhat relaxed. That's a very interesting state of mind and body-- interesting because it's somewhat ideal for cognitive work.
我们现在有了一个非常清晰的画面。奖赏回路被开启了。注意力被开启了。警觉性被开启了。你感觉比几分钟前要好。你的血压升高了。心率加快了。你思考的准备状态也提高了。然而你的身体又是某种程度上放松的。这是一种非常有趣的身心状态——有趣是因为它在某种程度上是进行认知工作的理想状态。
If you were going to sit down and work on a book or you were going to sit down and try and figure out a hard math problem or you're going to write a letter that's been really challenging for you to write or maybe that you're really excited to write but that you've been slow to get out the door for whatever reason here-- I'm talking about my own habits of procrastination-- well, that state of being very alert, but your body being relaxed, is almost, if not the optimal state for getting mental work done.
如果你要坐下来写一本书，或者你要试图解决一道难题，或者你要写一封对你来说非常具有挑战性的信，又或者可能你是真的非常兴奋要写但这封信由于某种原因一直被搁置——我是在谈论我自己的拖延习惯——好吧，那种高度警觉但身体放松的状态，几乎就是完成脑力工作时（如果不是最优的话）的最佳状态。
We're talking about one molecule, nicotine, found in plants like tomatoes and potatoes and the tobacco plant, one molecule that can trigger activation of all the circuits for focus and motivation in one fell swoop. That is remarkable.
我们讨论的是一种分子，尼古丁，存在于西红柿、土豆和烟草植物中，这种分子可以在一次性激活所有专注和动机回路。这太了不起了。
When I got in touch with Huberman and we sat down for a conversation, he said this stuff was obvious to him the first time he smoked a cigarette. He was 14, same time he had his first cup of black coffee.
当我联系上胡伯曼并坐下来交谈时，他说第一次抽烟时这些东西对他来说显而易见。他当时14岁，同时喝了第一杯黑咖啡。
I thought that was about as good as it gets until I took my first drag off a cigarette. And then I realized, wow, wow, wow, nicotine just makes everything look a little different-- feel focused and relaxed. That's a very hard combo for most people to just drop themselves into.
我原以为那已经很棒了，直到我抽了第一口烟。然后我意识到，哇，哇，哇，尼古丁让一切看起来都有点不同——感觉专注且放松。对大多数人来说，这是一个非常难以轻易达到的组合。
Unfortunately, nicotine also has a lot of harmful side effects. It constricts blood flow, can cause heart problems. And just to say the whole second half of the podcast is about how incredibly bad tobacco is for you. Huberman doesn't smoke anymore or use any kind of nicotine. I ran him through some of Allen Carr's claims about nicotine. And he did give me his take on them, although warily.
不幸的是，尼古丁也有很多有害的副作用。它会收缩血管，可能导致心脏问题。播客的后半部分都在讲烟草对你的危害有多大。胡伯曼现在不抽烟了，也不使用任何形式的尼古丁。我问了他一些关于亚伦·卡尔关于尼古丁的主张。他给了我他的看法，虽然有些谨慎。
I have to be careful because I don't want to discourage anyone from using a resource, like this book, that could help them move away from an unhealthy practice.
我必须小心，因为我不想阻碍任何人使用像这本书这样可能帮助他们戒除不良习惯的资源。
Sure, sure.
当然，当然。
So I don't want to undermine his efforts because I think that the effort is a noble and important one. But--
所以我不想破坏他的努力，因为我认为这项努力是高尚且重要的。但是——
He says Allen Carr's right, that you can get so dependent on nicotine that you don't derive any benefit anymore and just smoke so you can feel normal. That can happen with any addictive drug. But he says there are tons of studies supporting the idea that nicotine helps with focus. And no, it doesn't curb your stress. But it might make you better able to handle stress because you're more keyed up and vigilant. So if the central premise of the book is flawed and nicotine can do all of these enjoyable, useful things--
他说亚伦·卡尔是对的，即你可以对尼古丁产生严重依赖，以至于你不再从中获得任何好处，抽烟只是为了感觉正常。这在任何成瘾药物中都可能发生。但他表示，有大量研究支持尼古丁有助于专注的观点。不，它不能消除你的压力。但它可能让你更能应对压力，因为你更加警觉和清醒。如果书的核心前提是有缺陷的，且尼古丁确实能做所有这些令人愉悦、有用的事情——
Why do you think, if you were to conjecture, would this system that didn't work for me, per se, work for so many people when--
你认为，如果你来推测一下，为什么这个对我来说没用的系统，对那么多人却有用呢？
I was thinking about that. I think I know why. So from a neurobio-- I look at everything through the lens of biology, much to the discomfort of people close to me. But I can say that the book did a very interesting thing. I have to give him credit.
我在考虑这个问题。我想我知道为什么。从神经生物学角度——我透过生物学的视角审视一切，这让身边的人感到很不舒服。但我得说，这本书做了一件非常有趣的事情。我必须给它记上一功。
What he did is, he tried to bypass all the deeper biology of dopamine-acetylcholine addiction, et cetera. And what he did was, he said you've got a forebrain. Your forebrain can tell itself stories. By telling itself stories, you can set context. So let's tell yourself a story.
他所做的是，他试图绕过所有更深层的多巴胺-乙酰胆碱成瘾生物学等。他所做的是，他说你有一个前额叶。你的前额叶可以告诉自己故事。通过讲故事，你可以设置语境。那么，给自己讲个故事吧。
And the story is this. Withdrawal doesn't really exist. Or it exists but nicotine--
故事是这样的。戒断并不真正存在。或者它存在但尼古丁——
It's not that bad or whatever.
它没那么糟糕，或者之类的。
--the biology of nicotine doesn't really exist. And when you feel uncomfortable, that's-- in other words, he used the lack of knowledge about the way it really works, in the reader, to trick the reader into tricking themselves into bypassing what would potentially be a much more complicated process.
——尼古丁的生物学并不真正存在。当你感到不舒服时，那是——换句话说，他利用读者对真实运作方式的缺乏了解，来欺骗读者诱使自己绕过那原本可能是一个更复杂的过程。
Now for some people-- and apparently, celebrities-- it worked for them. But what if I came along with just the tiniest bit of knowledge to the contrary? Or what if someone like you has an experience to the contrary? Well then bam, you're right back in square one. I guess it just doesn't work for me. Or there's something wrong with me.
现在对一些人来说——显然包括名人——这对他们有效。但如果我带着一点点相反的知识出现呢？或者像你这样的人有了相反的体验呢？好吧，砰，你又回到了原点。我想它就是对我无效。或者是我自己有什么问题。
Something wrong with me. That's what I'd been feeling like. And that's sort of endemic to the method, like if it doesn't work, it's because you didn't follow all of the instructions. Or you didn't understand part of it. Read it again. Or call us. Or attend the live seminar.
“我自己有什么问题。”这就是我一直感觉到的。而这在某种程度上是这个方法所固有的，好像如果它无效，是因为你没有遵循所有的指示。或者你没理解其中的一部分。再读一遍。或者打电话给我们。或者参加现场研讨会。
In one edition of the book, Allen Carr writes that if you're thinking I'm still craving cigarettes after reading it, then quote, "you are being very stupid. How can you claim I want to be a non-smoker and then say I want a cigarette? That's a contradiction. If you say I want a cigarette, you're saying I want to be a smoker. Nonsmokers don't want to smoke cigarettes. You already know what you really want to be. So stop punishing yourself."
在书的一个版本中，亚伦·卡尔写道，如果你读完后还在想渴望香烟，那么引用他的话，“你太蠢了。你怎么能一方面声称我想成为一个非吸烟者，另一方面又说我想抽根烟？这是一种矛盾。如果你说我想抽根烟，你就是说我想成为一个烟民。非吸烟者不想抽烟。你已经知道你真正想成为什么样的人了。所以别再惩罚自己了。”
Having this information, knowing what nicotine was and is no longer doing to me, was comforting because I was like, it's not in my imagination. I wish I'd known all this before I'd stopped, that I'd had more of a map of the landscape, instead of just pretending I wasn't even on the continent.
拥有这些信息，了解尼古丁曾经并且不再对我做什么，让我感到安慰，因为我想：这不是我的想象。我希望在戒烟前就知道所有这些，我希望我能有一张更完整的地图，而不是假装我甚至不在那块大陆上。
This was March 31, the day after I talked with Huberman. It's three months in.
这是3月31日，我和胡伯曼谈话的第二天。已经三个月了。
I've been trying to get dressed for-- I don't know, like 10 or 15 minutes. Everything's just a little bit harder since I stopped smoking.
我一直在试图穿衣服——我不知道，大概10或15分钟了。自从我戒烟后，一切都稍微难了一点。
I'm slower. I'm slower. And I'll forget-- I mean, supposedly it's good for-- nicotine is good for working memory, meaning-- why did I come into the kitchen again? Oh, yeah.
我变慢了。我变慢了。我会忘记——我是说，据称这对——尼古丁对工作记忆有好处，意味着——我为什么又走进厨房了？哦，对了。
And I've no working memory anymore. And so it takes me forever to do simple things. And they're not as-- fun? That's not the word for getting dressed. But they're not-- it just feels like-- everything feels a little bit like a chore. Oh, goodness.
我的工作记忆没了。所以做简单的事情都要花我很久很久。而且它们没那么……有趣？那不是穿衣服的合适形容词。但它们不是——只是感觉——一切感觉都像是一种苦差事。哦，天呐。
There have been lots of news stories about Allen Carr's Easyway. He was interviewed a ton in the UK when he was alive. And the people who took over the organization after him have done a lot of press. But looking high and low, I hadn't seen anyone question the scientific accuracy of the method, even though most of the biology Huberman talks about has been known for a little while. So either I'm missing something, which happens a lot, or nobody's ever raised this particular issue with them before.
关于亚伦·卡尔的简单戒烟法有很多新闻报道。他在世时在英国接受过无数次采访。而在他之后接管组织的人也做了很多媒体公关。但我仔细查找了一番，没看到有人质疑这个方法的科学准确性，尽管胡伯曼谈到的大部分生物学原理已经被人们了解了一段时间了。所以要么是我错过了什么，这种情况经常发生，要么是之前没人向他们提出过这个问题。
So he'll be there. I did actually pour you a cup of--
所以他会在那里的。我确实给你倒了一杯——
Oh, that's fine Thank you.
哦，那很好，谢谢。
So I sat down with John Dicey, Allen Carr's successor. He's the global CEO and senior facilitator of Easyway now. He also took the seminar himself to quit smoking, and says he was so enthralled by how well it worked that he, quote, unquote, "hassled and harangued Allen Carr to let him get involved."
所以我坐下来和约翰·戴西（John Dicey）谈了谈，他是亚伦·卡尔的继任者。他现在是“简单戒烟法”的全球首席执行官和高级辅导员。他也参加了研讨会来戒烟，并说他被其效果之好迷住了，以至于他“缠着并骚扰亚伦·卡尔让他参与进来”。
They butted heads sometimes. But John really considers Carr to be a genius. I asked him if they'd ever talked about brain chemistry when Carr was alive. He said they had, although--
他们有时会意见不合。但约翰确实认为卡尔是个天才。我问他在卡尔在世时是否谈论过大脑化学，他说他们谈过，虽然——
He wasn't really interested in the science side--
他对科学那一面并不是真的很感兴趣——
He wasn't?
他不是？
No, I think he-- neither am I, really.
不，我想他——我其实也不是。
Really?
真的吗？
I've got to say, it's one of those things-- I don't really think it has much to bring to the table, if that makes sense.
我必须说，这是那种事情——我真的不认为它有什么能带来桌面上讨论的价值，如果这说得通的话。
Because he talked-- he would say that he was the world's leading expert on quitting smoking.
因为他谈到——他会说他是世界上最顶尖的戒烟专家。
Yes.
是的。
You're smiling as I say that.
你说这句话的时候在笑。
[LAUGHS]
[笑声]
So he wouldn't-- as the world's leading expert in quitting-- self-professed world's leading expert in quitting smoking-- be necessarily curious about that stuff?
所以他不会——作为世界上最顶尖的戒烟专家——自称世界上最顶尖的戒烟专家——对那些东西感到好奇吗？
Yeah, I think he was busy doing other things. So in terms of the Easyway method. It's now being applied to, I think it's 15 or 16 different addictions or issues.
是的，我想他当时正忙着做别的事情。所以就“简单戒烟法”而言，它现在正被应用到，我想是15或16种不同的成瘾或问题上。
There's the easy way to stop drinking, the easy weigh, W-E-I-G-H, to lose weight. There's one about being addicted to your phone-- lots of things. I should say an updated version of the book, different from the one I read, addresses brain science for the first time. But it's very selective. And it still claims nobody's ever had any pleasure or benefit from nicotine.
有《简单戒酒法》，《简单减肥法》（Weight拼写为Weigh，指称重），还有关于手机成瘾的等等——很多事情。我应该说，这本书的一个更新版本，与我读的那个版本不同，第一次涉及到了大脑科学。但它是非常有选择性的。它仍然声称没有人从尼古丁中获得过任何快乐或好处。
I started taking John Dicey through what I'd learned from Andrew Huberman, the research that contradicts what's in the book, and that might help explain why, for a lot of people, it's not going to be easy to walk away from smoking.
我开始带着约翰·戴西了解我从安德鲁·胡伯曼那里学到的东西，那些与书中所述相矛盾的研究，这或许有助于解释为什么对于很多人来说，放弃吸烟并不是一件容易的事。
So when the book says that it doesn't physically aid in concentration, just scientifically, it does aid in concentration.
所以当书里说它在生理上无助于专注时，在科学上，它确实有助于专注。
I told him. He's wrong.
我告诉他。他是错的。
You think he's wrong?
你认为他是错的？
I don't think he's wrong. I know he's wrong.
我不认为他是错的。我知道他是错的。
He's a neurobiologist.
他是神经生物学家。
I don't care what he is.
我不关心他是干什么的。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
That's what-- I'm not being disrespectful to him.
这不是——我并没有对他不敬。
Yeah, no, sure.
是的，不，当然。
He has a theory. His theory--
他有一个理论。他的理论——
Well, it's based on-- it's based on--
好吧，它是基于——它是基于——
He's just wrong--
他就是错的——
--tests--
——实验——
--on many levels. And I'm struggling to understand why there's a desperation to prove or believe that nicotine does something when it doesn't. I've never heard so much nonsense in my life. I'm sorry. Very nice guy, I'm sure. And I'm sure he believes what he's saying. But it's absolute nonsense.
——在很多层面上。而且我很难理解，为什么有一种绝望感要试图证明或相信尼古丁没有作用，当事实并非如此时。我这辈子从没听过这么多废话。我很抱歉。我相信他是个很好的人。而且我相信他相信他在说的话。但这完全是胡说八道。
I think that's where we're misunderstanding each other because I'm not looking for positives of nicotine. I was just looking for what is the mechanism. I was just like looking for what is the mechanism. And when I learned about the different neurochemicals that nicotine evokes in the brain, it just felt like-- that the method was predicated on a lie, that nicotine--
我想这就是我们互相误解的地方，因为我不是在寻找尼古丁的好处。我只是在寻找它的机制。我只是在寻找它的机制。当我了解到尼古丁在脑中唤起的不同神经化学物质时，我只是觉得——这个方法是建立在谎言之上的，尼古丁——
Your feeling is that you would-- you'll take nicotine for the rest of your life?
你的感觉是你将会——你打算这辈子都摄入尼古丁吗？
No, although--
不，虽然——
Why not?
为什么不？
Huh?
嗯？
Why not?
为什么不？
Well, it wasn't my plan. It wasn't my plan because--
好吧，那不是我的计划。那不是我的计划，因为——
Why isn't it your plan? Why isn't it your plan if it's giving you these tremendous benefits? You struggle without it. Why wouldn't you just take it for the rest of your life?
为什么那不是你的计划？如果它给了你这些巨大的好处，你没有它就很难熬。你为什么不这辈子都摄入它呢？
I think because there are health detriments that are nothing like--
我想因为有健康危害，这根本不是——
Things got spicy with John Dicey. He emailed me more than once, weeks after the fact, to say he was still reeling from the interview, doesn't understand why anyone would push back at the Allen Carr Easyway method. We've only ever done good in the world, he said. That's like kicking a cat. And why would anyone ever suggest there was a benefit to nicotine, other than maybe the tobacco companies or big pharma?
我和约翰·戴西的谈话变得很有火药味。在采访后的几周里，他不止一次给我发邮件，说他仍然对那次采访感到难以接受，不理解为什么会有人抵制亚伦·卡尔的“简单戒烟法”。他说，我们只在这个世界上做过好事。这就像踢猫一样。而且为什么会有人建议尼古丁有好处呢，除了可能烟草公司或大药厂？
If it was true, I could almost live with that. If nicotine did make it easier for people to concentrate, non-nicotine addicts to concentrate, I could live with that. I'm genuinely interested to look at the studies you've looked at. If there were advantages to it, I'd certainly acknowledge that. But there aren't. It's just--
如果这是真的，我几乎能接受这一点。如果尼古丁确实让人们更容易专注，让非尼古丁成瘾者更容易专注，我能接受。我真的很有兴趣看你读过的研究。如果它确实有优势，我肯定会承认。但并没有。它只是——
I guess, how can you say there aren't when you say that you haven't looked at the science, that it's just not-- and that's fine that it's not interesting to you. But when it's not interesting to you, and so you haven't really read about it, and Allen didn't really read about it, then how can you say it's not true?
我想，当你说你还没看科学研究，它对你来说不感兴趣时，你怎么能说它没有优势呢？而你说它对你没兴趣那没问题。但当它对你没兴趣，所以你没真正读过它，而亚伦也没真正读过它时，你怎么能说这不是真的呢？
It's just-- it's irrelevant, isn't it? I don't know. I wouldn't want to spend too much time discussing whether the moon is made out of cheese. I'm pretty sure it isn't.
这只是——这是无关紧要的，不是吗？我不知道。我不想花太多时间讨论月亮是否由奶酪做成。我很确定它不是。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Do you know what I mean? I think it's hugely dangerous to talk about that there might be benefits to nicotine when it's just simply not true. It's unfortunate the book didn't work for you. And I'm really sorry about that. And I wish you'd reached out for help at the time because it doesn't have to be this complicated. It really doesn't.
你知道我的意思吗？我认为谈论尼古丁可能有好处是极其危险的，因为这根本不是真的。很遗憾这本书对你没用。对此我真的很抱歉。我希望你当时能求助，因为它不必那么复杂。真的不必。
I'm really pleased you're not smoking. And I hope you're as well as you can be with the prognosis and everything like that.
我很高兴你不再抽烟了。而且我希望根据你的预后等等，你能尽可能好起来。
Yeah, thank you.
是的，谢谢。
If you think this understanding has helped you continue not smoking, that's brilliant. But you-- are you well? You sort of--
如果你认为这种理解有助于你继续戒烟，那太棒了。但你——你还好吗？你有点——
Thank you for asking. I think I'm OK. So basically, they say that the emphysema is mild, that it affects--
谢谢你的关心。我想我还可以。所以基本上，他们说肺气肿是轻度的，它影响——
John Dicey says the organization doesn't make any claims about the success rate of the book. For any measurable success, they always point to the seminar they give, which Allen Carr always said was about 90% effective. He based that figure on only about 10% of seminar goers taking advantage of the money-back guarantee. In order to get your money back, you have to do the session two additional times for free. Anyway, the company has backed off from that claim in recent years.
约翰·戴西说该组织不对这本书的成功率做任何宣称。对于任何可衡量的成功，他们总是指向他们提供的研讨会，亚伦·卡尔总是说它有大约90%的有效率。他基于只有约10%的研讨会参与者利用了退款保证这一数据。为了拿到退款，你必须额外免费参加两次会议。总之，该公司近年来已经不再声称这一说法了。
The seminar was put through a couple of randomized, controlled trials where it was pitted against methods that offer both behavioral support and pharmacology, nicotine replacement, that kind of thing. The more recent and bigger of those studies found that 19% of the Allen Carr people were still quit after six months versus 15% of the other group.
研讨会经历了几次随机对照试验，其中它与同时提供行为支持和药理学（如尼古丁替代等）的方法进行了对比。其中最近且规模最大的一项研究发现，6个月后，19%的亚伦·卡尔法参与者仍然成功戒烟，而对照组为15%。
With the margin of error, that basically means they're on par. Although 19% success still means that the method didn't work for four out of five people in the study. John Dicey told me he doesn't think those studies are a good reflection of what the results are, out in the real world.
考虑到误差范围，这基本上意味着它们旗鼓相当。尽管19%的成功率仍然意味着这个方法对研究中五分之四的人无效。约翰·戴西告诉我，他不认为这些研究能很好地反映现实世界中的结果。
I'm literally-- [COUGHS] --looking through my kitchen window, watching police officers smoke on the fire escape of the precinct.
我真的——[咳嗽]——正通过我的厨房窗户，看着警官在警局的防火梯上抽烟。
And this is four months in. Wherever you look, wherever you smell, there it is, your past.
而且这已经是四个月了。无论你往哪里看，无论你闻到什么，它都在那里，你的过去。
It's like you broke up with someone who was horrible for you. And then you leave your apartment and that person is on every street corner, wafting their perfume at you, which was and remains intoxicating, literally.
就像你和一个对你很糟糕的人分手了。然后你离开公寓，那个人就在每个街角，把他们的香水味飘向你，这曾经是，现在依然是令人陶醉的，字面意义上的。
And then you go back to the confines of your apartment. And you look out the window. And there they are, blowing kisses at a brick wall.
然后你回到公寓的狭窄空间里。你看向窗外。他们就在那儿，对着砖墙吹飞吻。
Now I can't tell whether I'm talking about the metaphor or the physical reality.
现在我分不清我是在谈论隐喻还是现实了。
I actually may have stumbled into a really good, though, kind of worrying explanation as to why I'm not in the percentile-- whatever it is-- of Allen Carr success stories. I talked with a prominent psychiatrist who's had patients that use the method. So she's familiar with the book. Her name is Anna Lembke. She runs the Addiction Medicine Dual Diagnosis Clinic at Stanford. She also wrote a book called Dopamine Nation, which is where I learned that nicotine increases dopamine levels by 150%, which is 50% more than sex.
事实上，我可能偶然发现了一个非常好的，尽管有点令人担忧的解释，为什么我不在亚伦·卡尔成功案例的百分比中。我与一位著名的精神科医生谈过，她有使用该方法的病人。所以她很熟悉这本书。她的名字是安娜·伦布克（Anna Lembke）。她在斯坦福大学经营成瘾医学双重诊断诊所。她还写了一本叫《多巴胺国度》（Dopamine Nation）的书，我就是从那里了解到尼古丁将多巴胺水平提高了150%，比性快感高出50%。
I called her to talk science. But our conversation became a little like a therapy session at some points. I told her there's this thing that happens in the shower when I first turn the water cold at the end. It makes you feel good after, not during. And weirdly, I don't just crave a cigarette right at that moment. It's this very specific sensation, like I'm taking a big whiff from a glass ashtray that I just emptied but haven't washed out yet. It's not a gross feeling. It's a wanting feeling.
我打电话给她是为了谈论科学。但我们的谈话在某些点上变得有点像心理治疗会议。我告诉她，当我在洗澡结束时把水调成冷水时，会发生一件事。它让你在那之后感觉很好，而不是过程中。奇怪的是，我并不就在那一刻渴望一根香烟。这是一种非常具体的感知，就像我从一个刚倒空但还没洗过的玻璃烟灰缸里深深地吸了一口气。那不是一种恶心的感觉。而是一种“想要”的感觉。
Does it happen immediately, when you turn the-- feel first feel the pain of the cold water?
它是在你打开——第一次感受到冷水的刺痛时立刻发生的吗？
Yes.
是的。
OK, so that's very interesting. There's a whole, famous series of experiments showing--
好的，那很有趣。有一个完整的、著名的实验系列表明——
She told me there were these studies done where they would take a rodent and get it addicted to some drug by letting it press a lever over and over again to receive that drug. But then if you take the drug out of the equation, it'll eventually stop hitting the button because-- what's the point? And then it wanders off to do other things in the cage to amuse itself. However--
她告诉我，有一些研究是这样的：他们取出一只啮齿动物，让它通过反复按压杠杆来获得某种药物，从而让它上瘾。但如果你把药物从等式中拿掉，它最终会停止按按钮，因为——有什么意义呢？然后它会游荡到笼子里做其他事情来娱乐自己。然而——
If, then, you take that same animal and you expose it to a painful foot shock, the animal will immediately run over to the lever and wildly start pressing it--
如果你随后取那只同样的动物，让它暴露在痛苦的脚部电击下，这只动物会立刻跑向杠杆并疯狂地开始按它——
Whoa.
哇。
--as a way to-- yeah, isn't that interesting? So I suspect that is what is happening to you, that by having cold-water showers, what you're doing is you're shocking your body with a painful stimulus, which is then triggering your automatic neurological safety and compensatory mechanism, which is to smoke a cigarette.
——以此来——是的，那不是很有趣吗？所以我怀疑这就是发生在你身上的事，通过洗冷水澡，你所做的是用痛苦的刺激电击你的身体，这随后触发了你的自动神经安全和补偿机制，也就是去抽一根烟。
Whoa. That's wild. Wow.
哇。这太狂野了。哇。
Yeah, yeah, in other words, you've created an elaborate, neurological circuit around smoking. And even months after you've stopped smoking, that neurological circuit is still healthy and firing away in response to significant stressors.
是的，是的，换句话说，你围绕吸烟建立了一个复杂的神经回路。即使在你戒烟数月后，那个神经回路仍然是健康的，并且在响应重大压力源时仍在运行。
People talk about the physical addiction to nicotine and the psychological addiction to nicotine. That sounds physical to me. It's--
人们谈论尼古丁的生理成瘾和心理成瘾。那听起来对我来说是生理上的。它是——
Oh, yeah, it's very physical.
哦，是的，非常生理。
[SIRENS WAILING]
[警笛声]
All this time, I'd been focusing on the damage that smoking had done to my lungs, 35 years worth of damage. I somehow hadn't thought in terms of doing that amount of damage to my brain too. That'll take a long time to repair, Anna Lembke told me, especially given my age. My brain isn't as plastic as it once was.
一直以来，我一直专注于吸烟对我肺部造成的损害，35年的损害。我不知怎么地没想过我也对大脑造成了同样数量的损害。安娜·伦布克告诉我，那需要很长时间才能修复，考虑到我的年龄。我的大脑不像以前那样具有可塑性了。
And there's another school of thought, she said, a more depressing one, which wonders whether the damage could be so far gone I can't repair it.
她说还有另一个思想流派，一个更令人沮丧的流派，怀疑损伤是否已经到了无法修复的地步。
It'll always be in this state of perpetual neurological withdrawal, which might require some kind of intervention.
它将永远处于这种永久性的神经戒断状态，这可能需要某种干预。
And in your case, that might look something like nicotine replacement therapies for life, potentially--
而在你的情况下，那可能看起来像是一辈子的尼古丁替代疗法，潜在地——
For life?
一辈子？
Hi-- what's that?
嗨——那是什么？
For life?
一辈子？
Yeah, for life, and potentially at higher doses than what you're currently taking.
是的，一辈子，而且潜在的剂量可能比你目前服用的还要高。
Wow.
哇。
So-- yeah, so we used to use nicotine replacement therapy just to help people quit. But more and more, we're now using them in the maintenance phase, where people are just using them for years to decades. And again, the thinking there is that wow, the ideal is that with sustained abstinence, your brain would heal and you would return to whatever your pre-smoking baseline was.
所以——是的，所以我们过去使用尼古丁替代疗法只是为了帮助人们戒烟。但越来越多地，我们现在在维持阶段使用它们，人们只是使用它们数年到数十年。同样，这里的想法是，哇，理想的情况是，通过持续的戒断，你的大脑会愈合，你将回到你戒烟前的基准状态。
But in reality, what we see is that some people don't get to that place, and that they may need some form of nicotine to feel and function OK, going forward, indefinitely.
但实际上，我们看到的是有些人并没有达到那个地步，他们可能需要某种形式的尼古丁来感觉和功能正常，在未来，无限期地。
Whoa. So it's possible that I've broken my brain, sort of, my dopamine receptors, to the point where they're just not going to return to normal?
哇。所以有可能我把我的大脑弄坏了，某种程度上，我的多巴胺受体，以至于它们将不会恢复正常？
Yeah. That's possible. I don't like to hear you say that your brain is broken. But I guess just to think about it a little differently, it just could be that you no longer have the brain plasticity to completely reverse the changes.
是的。那是有可能的。我不喜欢听你说你的大脑坏了。但我猜稍微换个角度想，可能只是你不再拥有能完全逆转这些变化的大脑可塑性了。
I had to listen back to that part of the interview a few times to fully feel the bomb drop of it. I know it's not an official diagnosis or anything or even an unofficial one. I don't want to overreact. But the impact is something like when I learned I have lung disease. Permanent brain changes and lack of plasticity makes me think of aging, which makes me think of dying. Nicotine replacement for life, for the rest of my life-- how long is that going to be?
我不得不把采访的那部分听了好几遍，才完全感受到它带来的震撼。我知道这甚至不是一个官方诊断或什么的。我不想反应过度。但这种影响就像当我得知我患有肺病一样。永久性的大脑变化和缺乏可塑性让我想到了衰老，让我想到了死亡。一辈子的尼古丁替代——那将会有多长？
And still, even assessing all of that damage, knowing all of the havoc that smoking has wreaked on my body, still I wish there was some dimension in which I could keep doing it. If you're wondering, it's now been seven months. And I still haven't smoked a cigarette. Every now and then, I almost wake up to it all over again, like, I'm still not doing that?
即便评估了所有那些损害，了解了吸烟对我的身体造成的浩劫，我依然希望有某种维度我能继续吸烟。如果你好奇的话，现在已经七个月了。我仍然没有抽过一根烟。偶尔，我几乎会为此再次醒来，就像，我还没做那件事吗？
Talking with Anna Lembke confirmed this idea that had been pecking at me since I first read the book. Allen Carr says there's only one kind of smoker and that any smoker can find it easy to quit. But I talked with a lot of people who had tried the method, folks it both worked for and didn't. And I just think there's different kinds of smokers.
与安娜·伦布克的谈话证实了这个想法，自读那本书起它就一直在我脑中盘旋。亚伦·卡尔说只有一种烟民，任何烟民都能轻松戒烟。但我与很多人谈过，他们尝试过这个方法，既有成功的人，也有没成功的人。我只是认为烟民有不同的类型。
I think there's a certain kind of smoker, like me, for whom there's just a lot of anger lurking in it. It's like every hour or a couple of hours, we climb up to the roof and fling ourselves off of it as a petulant fuck you to being alive. After all, we started doing this thing when we were kids, like 15, 16. No wonder there's such a delicious nihilism to it for some of us. It's like my 15-year-old fingers were still lifting the cigarette up to my 51-year-old lips.
我想有一种烟民，就像我这样，潜伏着很多愤怒。就像每一两个小时，我们就爬上屋顶，把自己扔下去，作为对活着的一种任性的“去你的”。毕竟，我们还是孩子的时候，15、16岁就开始做这件事了。难怪对我们中的一些人来说，有一种美味的虚无主义在里面。就像我15岁的手指依然把香烟递向我51岁的嘴唇。
I can't think of a lot of other behaviors that aren't associated with survival-- but it's even the opposite of survival-- that I did every day for that long. There's a line in one of the editions of the book I have, where Allen Carr writes, "if health, happiness, and freedom aren't enough to inspire you, then you have bigger problems than smoking." I underlined that passage. And in the margin, I wrote, "this is possible."
我想不出除了生存之外——但这甚至是生存的反面——我每天坚持做了那么久的其他行为。我有的书的一个版本里有一行字，亚伦·卡尔写道：“如果健康、幸福和自由不足以激励你，那么你的问题比吸烟更大。”我在那段话下划了线。在页边空白处，我写道：“这有可能。”
Coming up, when you wish you knew how and whether to quit someone, and then you receive possibly the most well-articulated relationship advice of all time. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，当你希望知道如何以及是否应该和某人分手，然后你收到了可能是有史以来最清晰表达的关系建议。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Sean Cole, sitting in for Ira Glass. Today's program, I Can't Quit You, Baby, stories of being on the verge of a big change, not wanting to let go, and the people who give you that final push.
这是《美国生活》。我是肖恩·科尔，代替艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，《我不能戒掉你，宝贝》，关于处于重大改变边缘、不想放手以及给予你最后一推的人们的故事。
We now present act two of our program. Act Two, A Spoonful of Sugar.
我们现在呈现节目的第二幕。第二幕，一勺糖。
When we were putting together this week's show, one of the other producers here thought of this advice column she read, years ago, where the person writing in wasn't sure if they should quit a relationship or not. It was the column Cheryl Strayed used to do, called Dear Sugar. Here's the letter.
当我们在策划本周节目时，这里的另一位制片人想到了她多年前读过的建议专栏，写信人不知道他们是否应该结束一段关系。那是谢丽尔·斯特雷德（Cheryl Strayed）曾经做的专栏，叫“亲爱的糖果”（Dear Sugar）。这是那封信。
"Dear Sugar, I'm in my early 20s. I've been in a serious relationship with the same guy for six years, on and off, and the off portion taking place when I was younger. I have been very distracted and have been second guessing the relationship for a while now. But I can't come to grips with losing this person, that seems to be right for me, permanently. And of course, I don't want to break his heart.
“亲爱的糖果，我二十出头。我和同一个男生维持了一段认真的关系已有六年，断断续续，‘断’的部分发生在我也年轻的时候。我一直非常分心，并且有一段时间对这段关系产生怀疑。但我无法接受永远失去这个人，他似乎是适合我的。当然，我也不想伤他的心。
Then again, I don't want to settle and have regrets later in life. I feel like we want different things out of life and we have different interests. But I just can't decide. I've talked to him about my feelings, for the record, but to no avail. We went on this little break. But god knows breaks never work.
话又说回来，我不想凑合，以后人生留有遗憾。我觉得我们对生活有不同的追求，也有不同的兴趣。但我就是无法决定。顺便说一下，我已经和他谈过我的感受，但无济于事。我们经历了这个小小的间歇。但上帝知道间歇从来都不管用。
Basically, my biggest fear is being alone and never finding anyone that measures up. It doesn't help that my closest friends are settling down with their boyfriends and are talking about marriage. Cringe. Honestly, I feel like marriage and that kind of commitment represents a loss of personal identity. I'm not sure why. But I would love your advice, Sugar. Please help. Sincerely, Scared and Confused.
基本上，我最大的恐惧是孤独，再也找不到任何衡量标准相当的人。最亲近的朋友们都在和男友安定下来，谈论结婚，这也没什么帮助。尴尬。老实说，我觉得婚姻和那种承诺代表了个人身份的丧失。我不确定为什么。但我很希望能得到你的建议，糖果。请帮帮我。诚挚的，害怕且困惑的人。”
Here's Cheryl Strayed, reading her response.
这是谢丽尔·斯特雷德在读她的回复。
Dear Scared and Confused, I lived in London when I was 20. I was technically homeless and desperately broke. But I didn't have the papers an American needs to get a job in London. So I spent most of my time walking the streets, searching for coins that people had dropped.
亲爱的害怕且困惑的人，我20岁时住在伦敦。我实际上无家可归，穷困潦倒。但我没有美国人在伦敦找工作所需的证件。所以我大部分时间都在街上走，寻找人们掉落的硬币。
One day, when I was searching for coins, a man in a business suit approached and asked me if I wanted an under-the-table job, three days a week at a major accounting firm that has since collapsed due to corruption. Sure, I said. And this is how I became coffee girl one two three.
有一天，当我正在找硬币时，一个穿着西装的男人走过来问我是否想要一份打黑工的工作，每周三天，在一家大型会计师事务所，那家公司后来因腐败而倒闭了。当然，我说。这就是我如何成为“咖啡女孩一二三”的。
Coffee girl was my actual job title. The one two three was tacked on to communicate the fact that I was responsible for providing coffee and tea to all the accountants and secretaries who worked on the first three floors of the building. It was a harder job than you might think.
咖啡女孩是我实际的工作头衔。“一二三”是附加在后面，为了传达这样一个事实：我有责任为大楼前三层工作的所有会计师和秘书提供咖啡和茶。这份工作比你想象的要困难得多。
Coffee girl, men would call, as I passed them with my tray, often snapping their fingers to draw my attention their way. I wore a black skirt over white tights and a black vest over a white shirt. And I was almost always out of breath.
“咖啡女孩，”当托着托盘经过时，男人们会这样叫我，经常打着响指来吸引我的注意。我穿着白色的紧身裤，外面是一条黑色的裙子，白衬衫外面是一件黑色的背心。我几乎总是气喘吁吁。
Banned from the elevator, I had to race up and down steps in a stairwell, that ran along the back of the building, to get from one floor to the next. That stairwell was my sanctuary, the only place where nobody snapped their fingers and called me coffee girl.
禁止乘坐电梯，我必须沿着大楼后方的一条楼梯井上下飞奔，才能从一层走到另一层。那条楼梯井是我的避难所，那是唯一没有人会打响指叫我“咖啡女孩”的地方。
During my breaks, I'd walk down to the first floor and go outside and sit on a patch of concrete that edged the building that housed the major accounting firm that has since collapsed due to corruption. One day while I was sitting there, an old woman came along and asked me where, in America, I was from. I told her. And she said that years before, she had visited the place in America where I'm from.
休息时，我会走到一楼去外面，坐在那栋后来因腐败而倒闭的大型会计师事务所大楼边缘的一片水泥地上。有一天，当我坐在那里时，一个老妇人走过来问我来自美国的哪里。我告诉了她。她说几年前，她去过我来自美国的那个地方。
We had a nice conversation. And each day after that, she came along during the time when I was sitting on the patch of concrete. And we talked. She wasn't the only person who came to talk to me. I was in love with someone at the time. In fact, I was married to that someone. And I was in way over my head.
我们进行了一次愉快的交谈。从那以后的每一天，她都会在我坐在水泥地上的那个时候过来。我们聊得很开心。她并不是唯一过来和我说话的人。当时我爱上了一个人。事实上，我嫁给了那个人。而且我陷得太深了。
At night, after I made love to this man, I would lie beside him and cry because I knew that I loved him but that I couldn't bear to stay with him because I wasn't ready to love only one person yet. And I knew that if I left him, I would die of a broken heart. And I would kill him of a broken heart too.
晚上，在和这个男人做爱后，我会躺在他身边哭泣，因为我知道我爱他，但我无法忍受留在他身边，因为我还没准备好只爱一个人。我知道如果我离开他，我会因心碎而死。我也会让他因心碎而死。
And it would be over for me when it came to love because there would never be another person who I'd love as much as I loved him, or who loved me as much as he loved me, or who was as sweet and sexy and cool and compassionate and good, through and through. So I stayed.
在爱这件事上我的人生就完了，因为再也不会有另一个人能让我像爱他那样爱，或者像他爱我那样爱我，或者像他那样甜美、性感、酷、有同情心且本质上那么好。所以我留了下来。
We looked for coins on the streets of London together. And sometimes, he would come and visit me at the major accounting firm that has since collapsed due to corruption, while I was on my breaks. One day, he came while the old woman was there. The man I love and the old woman had never come at the same time. But I had told him about her. And I had told her about him too.
我们在伦敦街头一起寻找硬币。有时，当我在休息时，他会来看我，就在那家后来因腐败而倒闭的大型会计师事务所。有一天，他在那个老妇人在的时候来了。我爱的人和那个老妇人从来没在同一时间来过。但我对他提起过她。我也对她提起过他。
"Is this your husband," the old woman exclaimed with jubilant recognition when he walked up. She shook his hand with both of her hands. And they chatted for a few minutes. And then she left. The man I loved was silent for a good while, giving the old woman time to walk away. And then he looked at me and said, with some astonishment, "she has a bundle on her head."
“这是你的丈夫吗？”当他走过来时，那个老妇人带着喜悦的认可惊呼道。她用双手握住他的手。他们聊了几分钟。然后她离开了。我爱的人沉默了很久，给了老妇人走远的时间。然后他看着我，带着些许惊讶说：“她的头上有一捆东西。”
"She has a bundle on her head," I said. "She has a bundle on her head," he said back. And then we laughed and laughed and laughed, so hard it might, to this day, still be the time I laughed the hardest. He was right. He was right.
“她的头上有一捆东西，”我说。“她的头上有一捆东西，”他回应道。然后我们笑啊笑啊笑，笑得那么厉害，以至于到现在，可能依然是我笑得最厉害的一次。他是对的。他是对的。
That old woman, all that time, all through the conversations we'd had as I sat on the concrete patch, had had an enormous bundle on her head. She appeared perfectly normal in every way but this one. She wore an impossible, 3-foot tower of ratty old rags and ripped up blankets and towels on top of her head, held there by a complicated system of ropes tied beneath her chin, and fastened to loops on the shoulders of her raincoat.
那个老妇人，在那段时间里，在我们坐在水泥地上进行的谈话过程中，头上一直顶着一个巨大的捆。她在其他方面看起来完全正常，只有这一点除外。她头上戴着一个由破旧的烂布、撕碎的毯子和毛巾组成的、不可思议的3英尺高的塔，由一套复杂的绳索系在下巴下方固定，并连接到她雨衣肩部的环上。
It was a bizarre sight. But in all my conversations with my husband about the old woman, I'd never mentioned it. "She has a bundle on her head," we shrieked to each other, through our laughter, on the patch of concrete that day.
那是一个奇怪的景象。但在我和丈夫关于那个老妇人的所有对话中，我从没提过它。“她的头上有一捆东西，”那一天我们在水泥地上透过笑声对着对方尖叫道。
But before long, I wasn't laughing any more. I was crying. I cried and cried and cried as hard as I'd laughed. I cried so hard I didn't go back to work. My job as coffee girl one two three ended right then and there.
但没过多久，我就不再笑了。我在哭。我哭啊哭啊哭，哭得跟我笑得一样厉害。我哭得太厉害，以至于没回工作岗位。我作为“咖啡女孩一二三”的工作就在那一刻结束了。
"Why are you crying," asked my husband as he held me. "Because I'm hungry," I said. But it wasn't true. It was true that I was hungry. During that time, we never had enough money or enough food. But it wasn't the reason I was crying.
“你为什么哭？”丈夫抱着我问。“因为我饿了，”我说。但这并不是事实。我的确饿了。在那段时间里，我们从来没有足够的钱或足够的食物。但这并不是我哭的原因。
I was crying because there was a bundle on the old woman's head, and I hadn't been able to say that there was, and because I knew that was somehow connected to the fact that I didn't want to stay with the man I loved anymore. But I couldn't bring myself to acknowledge what was so very obvious and so very true.
我在哭是因为那个老妇人的头上有一捆东西，而我无法说出这一点，而且我知道这在某种程度上与我不愿再留在我所爱的人身边这一事实有关。但我无法迫使自己承认那些如此明显且真实的事情。
That was such a long time ago, Scared and Confused. But it all came back when I read your letter. It made me think that perhaps that moment delivered me here to say this to you. You have a bundle on your head, Sweet Pea. And though that bundle may be impossible for you to see right now, it's entirely visible to me.
那是很久以前的事了，害怕且困惑的人。但读你的信时，一切又回来了。它让我觉得，也许那一刻把我送到这里，是为了对你说这些。你头上有一捆东西，亲爱的。虽然那捆东西对你来说现在可能无法看见，但对我来说完全可见。
You aren't torn. You're only just afraid. You no longer wish to be in a relationship with your lover, even though he's a great guy. Fear of being alone is not a good reason to stay. Leaving this man you've been with for six years won't be easy. But you'll be OK. And so will he.
你不是在纠结。你只是害怕。你不再希望与你的爱人保持关系，即使他是个好男人。害怕孤独不是留下的好理由。离开这个你相处了六年的男人并不容易。但你会好起来的。他也会。
The end of your relationship with him will likely also mark the end of an era of your life. In moving into this next era, there are going to be things you lose and things you gain. Trust yourself. It's Sugar's golden rule. Trust in yourself means living out what you already know to be true. Yours, Sugar.
你与他关系的终结很可能也标志着你人生一个时代的结束。在进入下一个时代的过程中，会有你失去的东西，也会有你得到的东西。相信你自己。这是糖果的黄金法则。相信自己意味着活出你已经知道的真实。你的，糖果。
When that producer brought it up at the weekly story meeting, someone else said that she had read the same column, and that it was what made her decide to divorce her husband. Said the same thing happened with a friend of hers, read the column, left the relationship. This is what I'm talking about, about a kind of spell being cast.
当那位制片人在每周故事会上提起它时，另一个人说她读过同样的专栏，正是它让她决定离婚。她说她的一位朋友也发生了同样的事，读了专栏，结束了关系。这就是我在谈论的，关于那种被施下的咒语。
Cheryl told us that of all of the thousands of letters she's gotten in the 13 years she's had the column, this is the most common predicament people find themselves in. All over the world, people are wondering, is it time to get out? Something like a third of all of her letter writers ask her this question.
谢丽尔告诉我们，在她拥有专栏的13年里收到的成千上万封信中，这是人们最常陷入的困境。世界各地的人们都在想，是时候离开了吗？大约三分之一的写信人都问她这个问题。
An adaptation of Cheryl Strayed's columns is now streaming on Hulu. It's called Tiny Beautiful Things. Our audio version of this column was produced by Diane Wu.
谢丽尔·斯特雷德专栏的改编剧集现在正在Hulu上流媒体播放。剧名叫《微小美好事物》（Tiny Beautiful Things）。我们这个专栏的音频版本由黛安·吴（Diane Wu）制作。
Act Three, Tender Resignation.
第三幕，温柔的辞职。
Sometimes the words that convince someone to quit a thing aren't advice, aren't supportive. But they're just as effective in getting you to let go, maybe more so. This next story is a case like that. And it's from producer, Zoe Chace.
有时劝说某人戒掉某事的词并不是建议，也不是支持性的。但它们在让你放手方面同样有效，甚至可能更有效。接下来的这个故事就是这样一个案例。它来自制片人佐伊·蔡斯（Zoe Chace）。
To start this next quitting story, I have to take you back a few months, to November, 2022, election night. We ran a story about an election administrator. Lots of people with that job have quit in the last few years because of harassment and death threats from people who believed the last election, or last elections, were stolen. Not this guy, not Heider Garcia in Tarrant County Texas, home of Fort Worth.
要开始这个下一个戒烟故事，我必须把你带回几个月前，2022年11月，选举之夜。我们做了一个关于选举管理员的故事。过去几年里，很多从事这份工作的人因为那些相信上次选举——或前几次选举——被窃取的人的骚扰和死亡威胁而辞职。不是这个人，不是德克萨斯州塔兰特县（Tarrant County）的海德·加西亚（Heider Garcia），沃斯堡的所在地。
He'd never be driven out by conspiracy theorists. In fact, he'd figured out, it seemed, this rare way to work with them, to invite them in.
他永远不会被阴谋论者赶走。事实上，他似乎找到了一种罕见的与他们合作的方法，邀请他们参与进来。
So there was this one time--
有一次——
One example-- during one election, one of the activists came in to where the votes are tallied. And this activist was like, if I were in charge, I would make the walls glass so you could see the election machines and where every cable goes. Heider was like, OK, I hear you.
一个例子——在一次选举中，一位活动人士来到计票的地方。这位活动人士说，如果我是负责人，我会把墙换成玻璃，这样你就可以看到选举机器和每根电缆的走向。海德说，好的，我听到了。
So I told him, what about if we rearrange the room so the machines are not in this little cabinet under the desk, but up where you can see them. And you can-- He said, well, maybe that would be a start.
所以我告诉他，如果我们重新安排房间，把机器不是放在桌下的小柜子里，而是放在你能看到它们的地方，怎么样？他说，嗯，也许那是一个开始。
So the next election, they came back in the runoff. When they walked in the room, I told them, all the machines are on top of the tables. You can see them back there, against the glass. They're labeled, what each one of them does. This is what you wanted, right? And so he had that moment of, OK, well, you got me on that one. And it's little things like that we keep doing, right?
所以下次选举，他们在决选中又来了。当他们走进房间时，我告诉他们，所有的机器都在桌子上。你可以看到它们就在后面，对着玻璃。它们被贴了标签，标明了每个机器的作用。这就是你们想要的，对吧？所以他有了那一刻，“好吧，你在这件事上说服我了。”我们一直在做这类小事，对吧？
Heider gave out his cell phone to anyone who wanted it. There was this one activist in particular, Aubree Campbell. She had this channel on Telegram about election fraud stuff. And she posted about Heider a lot. And she called him all the time. And she called him on election day.
海德把他的手机号码给了任何想要的人。其中有一位特定的活动人士，奥布里·坎贝尔（Aubree Campbell）。她在Telegram上有一个关于选举舞弊的频道。她经常发布关于海德的内容。她总是给他打电话。选举日那天她也给他打了电话。
So there's a picture going around. And it's and it's purported to be a map of outages of all of the machines. Is that-- are you having issues with that? I'm going to send it to you to-- just so you see what this is--
所以有一张照片正在流传。它据称是一张所有机器出现故障的地图。那是——你遇到这方面的问题了吗？我要把它发给你——只是为了让你看看这是什么——
All right. Yeah, send it to me. I'll take a look, see what it is. Please. That'd be great.
好的。是的，发给我吧。我会看看的，看看是什么。请。那太好了。
Yeah, I--
是的，我——
He and Aubree had built up a real relationship, even though they didn't agree on anything. She came by on election night to hang out and watch everything and ask more questions. It really seemed to me like nothing could deter him from this job. The reporter who brought us Heider's story, Natalia Contreras, she talks about Heider's radical patience with the election conspiracists who used to fill his office. And election administrators in the rest of the country looked to Heider as a model for transparency, openness, efficiency.
他和奥布里建立了真正的关系，尽管他们什么都不认同。她在选举之夜过来闲逛，观察一切并询问更多问题。在我看来，真的没有什么能阻止他从事这份工作。带来海德故事的记者纳塔利娅·孔特雷拉斯（Natalia Contreras）谈到了海德对那些曾经挤满他办公室的选举阴谋论者所持有的激进耐心。全国其他地方的选举管理员都把海德视为透明、开放、高效的典范。
The Secretary of State of Texas back then, not a Democrat, a very conservative guy, said to Natalia last year, if you were building a prototype for an elections administrator, you would just copy Heider Garcia.
当时的德克萨斯州州务卿，不是民主党人，是一个非常保守的家伙，去年对纳塔利娅说，如果你要建立一个选举管理员的原型，你只需要复制海德·加西亚。
But an April 16, 2023, Heider released a letter. It begins, gentlemen, please accept this letter as my formal resignation from the position as election administrator for Tarrant County. Five months after we ran that story, Heider had quit.
但在2023年4月16日，海德发表了一封信。开头写道：“先生们，请接受这封信作为我正式辞去塔兰特县选举管理员职务的申请。”在我们播出那个故事的五个月后，海德辞职了。
Some people in the county were pretty upset. They spoke up at this public meeting. One of the people was Aubree, the voter-fraud activist who was always questioning him.
县里的一些人非常不安。他们在这次公开会议上发言了。其中一个人是奥布里，那位总是质疑他的选举舞弊活动人士。
I was also shocked at Heider's resignation. I've been working with him. He is transparent. I want to give him that credit. It is a loss because he's built these systems. And he knows more about these computerized voting systems than most people on this planet. I don't think it's necessarily a win for the movement or for Tarrant County. But--
我也对海德的辞职感到震惊。我一直在和他工作。他是透明的。我想给他这个功劳。这是一个损失，因为他建立了这些系统。而且他比地球上大多数人都更了解这些计算机化投票系统。我不认为这对运动或塔兰特县来说一定是一次胜利。但是——
So what happened? Heider wouldn't talk about it for this story, citing his new job. He's on this federal election advisory committee now. But here's what we figured out. And a lot of this is based on Natalia's reporting for Vote Beat.
那么发生了什么？海德不会为了这个故事谈论它，提到了他的新工作。他现在在联邦选举咨询委员会。但这是我们查出的。而且这很大程度上基于纳塔利娅为Vote Beat所做的报道。
It actually all started the night we were down there, election night. One of the elections Heider was overseeing was for who would be his new boss, a position called County Judge, the guy who would be in charge of Tarrant County. The winner was a man named Tim O'Hare. He heavily featured election-fraud issues in his campaign, claiming that voter fraud is rampant-- it is not-- that the 2020 election was possibly stolen from Trump-- it was not.
其实这一切都始于我们在那里那个晚上，选举之夜。海德监督的选举之一是选出他的新老板，一个叫县法官的职位，也就是负责塔兰特县的人。获胜者是一个叫蒂姆·奥黑尔（Tim O'Hare）的男人。他在竞选中大肆宣扬选举舞弊问题，声称选民欺诈猖獗——事实并非如此——声称2020年选举可能是从特朗普那里窃取的——事实并非如此。
Heider had dealt with scores of election skeptics. But now one was his boss. One of the first things Tim O'Hare did, when he got into office a few months ago, was set up an Election Integrity Task Force, like he'd promised during his campaign, to investigate election crimes. There was a big press conference.
海德处理过无数选举怀疑论者。但现在其中一个成了他的老板。蒂姆·奥黑尔上任后的头几件事之一，是在几个月前设立了一个选举诚信特别工作组，就像他在竞选中承诺的那样，来调查选举犯罪。举行了一场大型新闻发布会。
We encourage everyone to report actions that they have concerns about, whether it's at the voting booth, whether it is--
我们鼓励每个人举报他们担心的行为，无论是在投票站，还是——
Heider was not consulted about the task force. And when the task force was announced, he was not there. A reporter asked if Heider was part of the Task Force.
海德没有被咨询关于特别工作组的事。而当特别工作组宣布时，他不在那里。一位记者询问海德是否是特别工作组的一员。
The Task Force is made up of investigators and deputies. So he is-- I fully expect him to cooperate with it. But he's not part of the Task Force, per se.
特别工作组由调查员和副手组成。所以他是——我完全期待他配合。但他本身不是特别工作组的一员。
It's worth mentioning even if you believe there is a major problem with voter fraud, which lots of officials in Texas do, Tarrant County got a special shout out in the big 2020 election audit that Texas did for running its election so smoothly, a quote, "quality, transparent election." That was Heider.
值得一提的是，即使你相信存在严重的选民欺诈问题，德克萨斯州的许多官员也这样认为，但塔兰特县在德克萨斯州进行的大型2020年选举审计中获得了特别称赞，因为其选举运行得如此顺利，被引用为“高质量、透明的选举”。那就是海德。
So the Election Integrity Task Force was one thing. They also fought over the budget. Money had been approved for Heider to buy an expensive attachment for a mail-sorting machine. But O'Hare wouldn't vote to release the funds for it. There was an awkward back and forth at a public meeting, with O'Hare questioning him, like, why was this necessary.
所以选举诚信特别工作组是一回事。他们还在预算上发生了争执。批准的资金是让海德购买一个昂贵的邮政分拣机附件。但奥黑尔不会投票释放资金。在一次公开会议上，双方进行了尴尬的来回，奥黑尔质问他，比如，为什么这是必要的。
Is there some other way that it's going to save money? Because that's not saving money.
有没有其他方法可以省钱？因为那不是在省钱。
No.
没有。
OK.
好的。
No. This is not an investment to save money. This is an investment to make a labor incentive.
没有。这不是为了省钱的投资。这是一种劳动激励的投资。
Did you not say, earlier, that you thought it would save money?
你不是之前说过你认为它会省钱吗？
Nope. No, no, I said I don't even think that I can come up with a number to save money. We're never going to get $150,000 back in year one. That's not what I'm here to-- it's an investment in a cleaner, smoother, more efficient operation. But it's not a case of saving money.
没。不，不，我说我甚至认为我无法给出一个省钱的数字。我们第一年永远拿不回那15万美元。那不是我来这里的目的——这是一个对更清洁、更平稳、更高效运营的投资。但这不是省钱的问题。
I think this is a total waste. OK.
我认为这完全是浪费。好的。
This was a real change for Heider, the golden boy of Texas elections. To a certain degree, what made Tarrant County elections so secure, efficient, and transparent was the pricey election equipment. So Heider was accustomed to getting his requests approved. Heider's previous boss, a Republican, once told Vote Beat, "if Garcia tells us he needs something, then we're going to get it for him."
这对比海德来说是一个巨大的改变，他是德克萨斯州选举的“金童”。在某种程度上，使塔兰特县选举如此安全、高效和透明的是昂贵的选举设备。所以海德习惯于让他的请求得到批准。海德的前任老板，一位共和党人，曾经告诉Vote Beat：“如果加西亚告诉我们需要什么，那么我们就会为他弄到。”
Around this time, Heider and Tim O'Hare met in his office, where things clearly did not go well. Heider mentioned it at the end of his resignation letter. it ends, "Judge O'Hare, my formula to administer a quality, transparent election stands on respect and zero politics. Compromising on those values is not an option for me. You made it clear in our last meeting that your formula is different, thus my decision to leave. I wish you the best. Tarrant County deserves that you find success."
大约在这个时候，海德和蒂姆·奥黑尔在他的办公室里会面，事情显然进展得不顺利。海德在他的辞职信结尾提到了这一点。信末写道：“奥黑尔法官，我管理高质量、透明选举的公式建立在尊重和零政治的基础上。妥协这些价值观对我来说不是一种选择。你在我们最后一次会议中明确表示你的公式是不同的，因此我决定离开。祝你一切顺利。塔兰特县值得你找到成功。”
I reached out to Tim O'Hare. He didn't respond. But one thing that came out later, on a radio show that O'Hare was on, was he didn't like the way Heider talked to reporters-- at all. That seems like a central problem he had with Heider. He said someone had given him a public-records request of Heider's communications. And he didn't like what he saw in his texts with the press. Funny. That was my favorite thing about Heider.
我联系了蒂姆·奥黑尔。他没有回应。但后来在奥黑尔参加的一个电台节目中出现了一件事，就是他不喜欢海德与记者交谈的方式——一点也不喜欢。那似乎是他对海德的一个核心问题。他说有人给了他一份海德通讯的公共记录申请。他不喜欢他在与媒体的短信里看到的内容。有趣。那是我关于海德最喜欢的事情。
So it was one guy that got Heider to go. After dealing with countless voter-fraud activists over the years, Heider and Tim O'Hare had a meeting. And then Heider quit. Or you could say it was more than one guy. O'Hare had been put in office by the voters, in an election that Heider had made sure it was fair.
所以就是一个家伙让海德离开的。在多年处理无数选民欺诈活动人士之后，海德和蒂姆·奥黑尔举行了一次会议。然后海德辞职了。或者你可以说是不仅仅是一个家伙。奥黑尔是选民选上台的，在一次海德确保公平的选举中。
Heider's last day was Friday, May 19. Aubree gave Heider a copy of The Federalist Papers. She inscribed it, "thank you for your assistance with my current understanding of Texas election procedures. Please take time to relax. And I hope you enjoy perusing these early writings of the founding fathers."
海德的最后一天是5月19日星期五。奥布里给了海德一份《联邦党人文集》。她在上面写道：“感谢你对我目前对德克萨斯州选举程序的理解提供的帮助。请花时间放松一下。我希望你喜欢研读这些开国元勋的早期著作。”
When we drove away from Heider's office that election night in 2022, I felt like we had witnessed this little scene that could be a model for how elections offices could be in the election-conspiracy era, where the administrators and the skeptics would be able to-- if not agree, at least coexist through elections. Heider, running around, making sure his workers were getting what they needed, while all night long, this one woman in a red, white, and blue dress followed the ballot bags around with a clipboard, taking notes.
当我们离开海德的办公室时，那是2022年的那个选举之夜，我觉得我们目睹了这一小幕，它可能成为选举办公室在选举阴谋时代如何运作的典范，在那里管理员和怀疑论者能够——即使不是达成一致，至少也能通过选举和平共处。海德跑来跑去，确保他的工作人员得到了他们需要的东西，而整晚，这个穿着红白蓝裙子的女人用夹板跟着选票袋，记着笔记。
It felt oddly peaceful, stable. I was kind of optimistic. Yeah no-- six months later, I don't see it that way.
感觉异常平静、稳定。我当时有点乐观。是的，不——六个月后，我不这么看了。
Zoe Chace is one of the producers of our show.
佐伊·蔡斯是我们节目的制片人之一。
The program was produced today by Aviva DeKornfeld. The people who put together today's show include Jane Ackermann, Bim Adewunmi, James Bennett II, Phia Bennin, Chris Benderev, Jendayi Bonds, Michael Comite, Valerie Kipnis, Miki Meek, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Sara Parish, Nadia Reiman, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker.
节目今天由阿维瓦·德科恩菲尔德（Aviva DeKornfeld）制作。今天参与制作节目的人员包括简·阿克曼（Jane Ackermann）、比姆·阿德温米（Bim Adewunmi）、詹姆斯·贝内特二世（James Bennett II）、菲亚·贝宁（Phia Bennin）、克里斯·本德列夫（Chris Benderev）、詹达伊·邦兹（Jendayi Bonds）、迈克尔·科米特（Michael Comite）、瓦莱丽·基普尼斯（Valerie Kipnis）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、萨拉·帕里什（Sara Parish）、娜迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、弗朗西斯·斯旺森（Frances Swanson）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emmanuele Berry. Special thanks today to Nikki Glaser, Jennifer White, William Georgides, Anthony Perullo, Viki Merrick, Ben Bianccini, Aditya Murkerji, Grace McCants, Julie Snyder, Rob Mohr, Gary Holl, Jamie Knapp, and Miranda Suarez.
我们的执行主编是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃勒·贝里（Emmanuele Berry）。特别感谢今天的妮基·格拉泽（Nikki Glaser）、詹妮弗·怀特（Jennifer White）、威廉·乔治德斯（William Georgides）、安东尼·佩鲁洛（Anthony Perullo）、维基·梅里克（Viki Merrick）、本·比安奇尼（Ben Bianccini）、阿迪蒂亚·穆尔克吉（Aditya Murkerji）、格蕾丝·麦坎茨（Grace McCants）、朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）、罗布·莫尔（Rob Mohr）、加里·霍尔（Gary Holl）、杰米·纳普（Jamie Knapp）和米兰达·苏亚雷斯（Miranda Suarez）。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange, and our website, thisamericanlife.org, where we have all this new merch, great new t-shirts, lots of stuff. There's a beautiful illustration of our show's co-founder, Torey Malatia, on one of the shirts. Go check it out, thisamericanlife.org.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）送到公共广播电台，我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org，那里有所有这些新周边、很棒的新T恤、很多东西。衬衫上有一幅我们节目联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）的精美插图。去看看吧，thisamericanlife.org。
Thanks, as always, to my boss, Ira Glass. He was in the park the other day. And he jumped into this double Dutch routine with some kids. He was like, left, right, cross, turn. He was a natural. Killed it. And very proud of himself. "I mean, that's a very hard combo for most people to just drop themselves into."
像往常一样，感谢我的老板艾拉·格拉斯。他前几天在公园里。他跳进了和一些孩子玩的双荷兰跳绳游戏中。他就像是，左，右，交叉，转。他是个天生的。搞定了。他为自己感到非常自豪。“我是说，那对大多数人来说是一个非常难以直接参与的组合。”
I'm Sean Cole, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是肖恩·科尔，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。